welcome everybody it is almost time once
again for the almost daily White House
coronavirus press briefing I am thrilled
that you are joining me so that I don't
have to watch these atrocities by myself
we are live on Twitter twitch YouTube
and Facebook and boy do we have a lot to
discuss today we are of course going to
talk about bleaching the lungs and
disinfecting with lice all of the veins
and all of that stuff and we will talk
about I mean there's just so much to
discuss so I look forward to it a few
Super chats that came in just while we
were waiting to get started they aren't
on screen but I will read them anyway
Zachary Foster says studies now coming
out show growth rate has no difference
in lockdown or not what are your
thoughts yeah I discussed this yesterday
so it increasingly seems like it's
possible that coronavirus has about an
80-day curve and the curve is the same
whether or not there's a lockdown now
what's different is the number of cases
and the number of deaths the curve can
be the same the trajectory can be an
80-day trajectory no matter what but you
could have more or fewer cases and
deaths and we're going to do a deep dive
on that Oh a lot of running around going
on all of a sudden that's weird we're
going to do a deep dive on that on
Monday anybody know what's happening
like why are so many people so quickly
walking through the the press briefing
room it's odd very weird I've never seen
that happen before in any case yes we
are we discussed that yesterday Andrew
Moore says you're the only commentator
my girlfriend tolerates because you
don't yell or scream keep up the call
rational analysis David thank you zesty
African says zhudi booty patootie by the
way new intercept article on Tara Reid
and Biden came out will the meet who
backlash ever reach Biden Danny Thompson
says now Trump says he was being
sarcastic about the comments yesterday
that's his go-to excuse for when he says
something so dumb he can't back out
besides he has no sense of humor much
less sarcasm yeah I'm gonna talk about
that momentarily Trump doesn't even know
what sarcasm means I think Trump doesn't
know the difference between telling a
joke and being sarcastic and it's it's
all insane Kent
five says thank you for being a beacon
of reason and truth especially in these
times david love from LA and kevin
mccomber says you should debate steven
crowder doubt he would do it and nicole
gray says I'll only watch with your
commentary I'm going to I'll get back to
the Super chats momentarily but there's
a few other things that I want to go
through as people they're coming in here
I'm just going to go kind of in reverse
order on my Twitter page yesterday of
course Donald Trump talking about what
about injecting disinfectant what about
injecting disinfectant a question that
probably some of you are thinking of
this year totally into that world we're
not going to be very interesting so
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or
just very powerful light yeah and I
think you said that hasn't been checked
but you're gonna test it and then I said
supposing you brought the light inside
the body you can which you can do either
through the skin or in some other way
yeah and I think you said you're gonna
test that too
sounds interesting right right and then
I see the disinfectant weird knocks it
out in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number also can you imagine
having been briefed by the top medical
experts for three months and the way
that you characterize the illness at
that at this point is that you've heard
it does a tremendous number on the lungs
can anybody imagine being that out of
touch rusting to check this so that
you're gonna have to use medical doctors
with but it sounds it sounds interesting
to me yeah so listen Trump was not being
sarcastic and he was not kidding and he
did say it that's it and it's funny
because trumpets are falling all over
themselves with conflicting defenses
some are saying he didn't say it like
Scott Adams the guy who draws the
Dilbert cartoons who I know and I've
interviewed he said this was an IQ test
and if you think that Trump said what
about in Jack
thing disinfectants you failed the test
no no he definitely said it but the
funny thing is then Trump said he was
being sarcastic so it's like well if
your defense is he didn't say it your
that goes in direct conflict with he
said it but it was a joke this is funny
that someone may oh no wait hold on I'll
get back to this this is what this was
we will have last night on Twitter
somebody made that this is pretty funny
you can check this out if you're
interested I won't play at all whether
it's ultraviolet or just very powerful
light and I think you said that hasn't
been checked but you're going to test it
and then I said supposing you brought
the light inside the body you can which
you can do either through the skin or in
some other way and I think you said
you're gonna test that too sounds
interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
we've knocks it out in a minute one
minute I think you guys get it so I like
that here's dr. Burks now listen the
whole dr. Brooks thing it's like okay
she realizes this is bonkers but she's
increasingly enabling Trump's this
information and even perpetuating some
of it the body with a tremendous just
very powerful light and then I said
supposing you brought the light inside
the body you can which you can do either
through the skin or in some other way
and I think you said you're gonna test
that very uncomfortable very deep
breaths so anyway this even even for her
it's too stupid and then this is just
the best this is dr. Steven Hahn the FDA
guy trying to explain away the crazy
stuff that Trump said keep an eye on dr.
Sanjay Gupta in the middle whose
expression just about says it all about
possibly dealing with the coronaviruses
we've been getting all the questions
about it and
just want to play it and and and ask you
about it okay so let me say just once is
that first of all about treating the
body with light and somehow bringing the
light inside the body where do you fall
on that so I think the data that were
presented at the press conference today
were really important in terms of what
kills the virus and I believe the
president was asking a question that
many Americans are asking which is okay
this is what kills the virus it's a
physical agent in this case you bite how
could that be applied to kill the virus
and for example a human being we have
plenty of examples in medicine where
light therapy has been nice can you
imagine so like for example you might
get one of those special lamps to deal
with seasonal affective disorder in the
winter burn diseases so it's a natural
question that I is a doctor not expected
to hear from from someone as a natural
extension of the data that we're so
obviously that's not an answer which is
why but I mean there might be a delay
but also just kind of the weird silence
where it's like that's your whole answer
but just from a medical standpoint I
mean you wouldn't would you
I mean there's people who were listening
obviously the president knighted States
and take what he says very seriously
are you concerned at all from a medical
standpoint of somebody you know
injecting themselves with a disinfectant
or you know hearing what the president
said and this is trying to experiment on
themselves thinking that might be
something worth looking at there's is
there any evidence about taking a
disinfectant that's used you know on the
table where I'm sitting and using it
internally that doesn't seem like a good
idea or does it I mean am I wrong yes I
think it's an excellent point you're
making you you we certainly wouldn't
want as a physician someone to take
matters in their own hands I think this
is a something that a patient would want
to talk to their physician about right
and no I certainly wouldn't recommend
the internal ingestion of a disinfectant
again this is a conversation that occurs
every day in America between up everyday
doctors and patients discuss
should I inject bleach or should I not
inject bleach should I drink Lysol or
should I these are the questions that
because of our phenomenal system doctors
and patients can have with each other
not with the intervention of the
government every single day so that's
insane let me see what else so I bleep
ou stood that Oh a bunch of people made
some good eye I had this idea and people
put it together in a number of different
ways bleach chewables treats coronavirus
what do you have to lose that one's
pretty good
Lysol brand sort of like Binaca now in a
convenient breath spray to get those
insides clean kills 99.9% of coronavirus
what do you have to lose that's a good
one Clorox chewables kills 99.9% of
germs Trump recommended don't die maybe
I like that one as well and then oh
maybe I'll do the Rudy Guiliani thing in
a little bit one other thing oh we could
do maybe the tuna-melt thing in a little
bit I can critique people some bites
sometimes people like when I do cooking
related stuff I will do critiques of the
tuna-melt maybe if people behave I will
do it and then here is an important
point that I want to just bring up I
tweeted this earlier the scariest part
about the injecting disinfectants Fiasco
isn't that Trump is so dumb and he is
but that despite being briefed by
experts for months he's still imagining
that this meaning injecting
disinfectants could be the type of
solution that might materialize he
simply doesn't understand the problem
like it you know for three months now
he's been briefed by the top medical
experts about vaccinations treatments
convalescent plasma or plasma is he all
this different stuff and it still occurs
to him that [ __ ] maybe we should be
injecting Lysol like maybe injecting
bleach is all we need to do here that's
really the scary and dangerous part so
we'll get back in a little bit to Rudy
Giuliani I want to see if we have
updated testing data from today we did
finally on Wednesday and Thursday we
finally had better testing numbers we
tested five hundred thousand people on
Wednesday and Thursday we need to double
that so we can test five hundred
thousand in one day instead of two but
I've been keeping and these are
typically updated at
p.m. have not been updated today I will
keep an eye on them as we wait for the
start of today's Trump coronavirus press
briefing let me thank a couple of people
Thomas Fant is today's new member number
one at join pakman.com and Seija
benin benjaminson is new member number 2
today at join pakman.com very very much
appreciate the support really quick I
will just say I would very much
appreciate it if you went to my website
join pakman.com and grabbed a membership
we're down close to 600 paid members
since the start of the virus and it's
because everybody's suffering 20% of the
country's seemingly close to 20% has
lost their jobs altogether people are
tightening the belt we've got food lines
we've got all of this stuff we
fortunately so far have not had to do
any staffing reductions hours reductions
any of that stuff I'm streaming
essentially daily in addition to doing
the broadcast show in the podcast and
the radio show in the YouTube clips to
balance out the 35% reduction in YouTube
revenues so I don't want your last
dollar or two we're still doing the
stream for everybody that's the whole
point of this but if you have a couple
bucks a month consider getting a
membership at join pakman.com I will
thank you profusely on stream we also
are including just to make it easy if
you want to sign up on patreon instead
you can do it
patreon takes a little bit of a bigger
slice then our website does slices but
everybody gets to thank you our website
which previously has crashed when I say
hey maybe sign up the resources on our
website have been quadrupled it held up
beautifully yesterday not a single
glitch on the website to my knowledge
and every single one of you will get a
sincere and profuse thank you from me
who signs up and one per oh one person
who just did is Holly York Holly Thank
You Holly you are a fantastic person and
a true mensch a supporter of independent
media very much appreciative ok let me
do a few other super chats as we're
waiting here
Jacob Ratner says any worries about
conflicts with China due to Trump of
course
yeah we've been covering China for a
while that's a major concern hold on a
second I just lost a bunch of these
where did those go oh here we go
Paul JM says Ecuador has 11,000 new
cases today according to world ometer x'
is it a glitch I don't know let's take a
quick look at that Ecuador Ecuador Wow
that that must be a glitch let me
refresh and see if it went away no it's
still there I just don't know I just
it's too early for me to say it could be
a glitch we've seen it before
but I am Not sure Erick lamont says
happy Friday David and fellow viewers
let's get through our daily dose of
insanity and unplugged for the weekend
let's do it let me say thank you to
Margo Cabot for subscribing with twitch
prime Wow
also crimson Elric has subscribed with
prime and says keep up the good work
David don't let them distract us with
dots on a map indeed we will not indeed
will not thanks to everybody watching on
twitch very much appreciate it um let's
see here
Mavis Leyva's says thoughts on the White
House hot mic vaccine video with John
Roberts I think he's just kind of an
idiot I don't really think much else of
it there were people who started coming
up with a lot of different conspiracies
and I just think he's kind of dumb I
don't I don't attribute too much else to
it
doom lore says very powerful light like
a laser beam there's an idea yeah laser
laser the lungs
Alexander the Snivy says I wonder if the
White House staff had to hide the Clorox
and Lysol after he suggested injecting
it into people no Trump doesn't do it so
when Trump was promoting chloroquine and
people would ask him are you gonna take
it he said you know oh I'm thinking
about it I maybe I will but he never
does this stuff it's just for other
people that he suggested it Trey
Earnhardt says what is the best tasting
bleach I find citrus citrus ooh notes
are typically best with bleach Mike
amazin says love the show please tell my
wife Danielle to vote this year
yes Danielle vote you must vote this
call call in when we take live calls and
we can discuss why you might not vote
kwik-e-mart says so there is a device
called the heel light made by a 2-u
Biosciences for the UV light but looking
at the video not sure how it gets deep
in the lung yeah there's a bunch of
people who have been saying hey you know
there are like their lights for seasonal
mood disorders and there's UV therapy
and all this stuff we're talking about a
virus an upper respiratory virus and
anybody trying to person Trump already
said he was only being sarcastic which
is a lie but unless you believe he's
lying he's admitted to sing he's
admitted to saying it's up anyway we're
not if they're not going to say you know
what this was stupid if they don't take
the loss on this there's no talking
sense into them don't even bother
holy fook says what are the Joe Biden's
sexual assault accusations and ho-lee
fook says will you debate Kyle kolinsky
over voting Biden that is the user who
trolls daily who used to be known as dr.
Anthony Fauci Alex Jones Stephen Kenneth
Destiny's bonel the second I believe
maybe rat Packer as well as Hugh Jass
and they just try to stir stuff up Joel
Harris says hey David watching with my
daughters would you say hi to Grayson
Maddy they were excited yesterday
hearing dad's name on TV and I
subscribed Grayson Maddy hello I hope
that you are enjoying the isolation and
the quarantine it sounds like your dad
is a good guy and you know don't don't
give him too much grief when he doesn't
do what you want
Zuko ax says is any other country
besides the u.s. having protests against
being in lockdown is Trumpets the only
ones not taking the situation seriously
so in Brazil there have been some
protests to reopen look at who's in
charge in Brazil right and there have
been some other small ones but nobody is
experiencing what the US is experiencing
in terms of the protests Jerry Hickel
says we should all inject Lysol yay
Trump holy fook says thoughts on Kyle :
he's saying I don't know what Kyle said
and I'm not gonna respond to things that
I can't verify Matt bond says they
already had tied pod caps yes
Townsend Koch says Trump used inject
because when Bryan was talking about
sunlight and humidity he said inject UV
light as in add UV light to the equation
of summer he Trump interpreting it a
little too literally
maybe holy fook says how did Trump
mishandle the pandemic response I have a
20-minute video about it I don't want to
redo video clips I've done Kevin
Macomber says someone on the Left needs
to debate Crowder well look up sam
cedars video about debating steven
crowder and you might find out very
quickly why we have not seen such
debates so far papayas has upgraded
their membership to beta oh hold on a
second ah Dax
says it's almost like watching Monty
Python's Flying Circus yeah the crazy
thing is that there is no more
distinguishing the press conferences
from parodies of the press conferences
they are one in the same there's there's
essentially no difference you can't even
really do a parody of what's going on
because the real thing is crazier right
like inject the idea of injecting
disinfectants how do you parody that
with something crazier you really can't
chill says can you play liar tweets
tonight for everyone I I don't want to I
think that the the I'm gonna have
copyright issues if I do that so I don't
want to do that right now
Dave Garr says phototherapy is a thing
though it's used to treat neonatal
hyperbilirubinemia bad baby kidneys keep
up the great content thanks listen Trump
didn't know that and that's not a
respiratory illness
thanks to Heda for the super chat
Matthias Germany says David who could
convince Trump to resign maybe his kids
I don't I really don't know that anybody
could I don't know Mike tilling has
subscribed on YouTube CJ sacks be 787
Williams says I'm a FedEx delivery
driver we're getting killed out here
show some love for us yeah
huge thank you to the delivery drivers
although at the same time you know we've
got to keep the delivery drivers safe
just saying thank you for being in
danger doesn't seem to really cut it but
but I do appreciate that I have received
packages let me put it that way
Alexandra Stevenson says how can I gift
a David Pakman memberships there are
people who cannot afford a membership
how can I sponsor some so the easiest
way to gift or sponsor memberships is
you sign up you've got to be logged out
to do this you sign up you put in the
recipients name the recipients email and
you pay for it but then you've got to
tell them what their password is we
really don't have a good system for that
right now unfortunately the best place
to gift memberships is actually twitch
twitches is is the which has an
infrastructure for doing this it's a
beautiful infrastructure in fact a user
who goes by the name turkey bacon and
cheese has gifted 250 subscriptions to
people if you can imagine another user
named donkey show has gifted 86 it's
amazing the number of subscriptions that
have been gift gifted if somebody's
asking by the way I noticed whether I'm
5 foot 5 no I'm 5 foot 8 5 foot 8
Michaela McGonagall says happy Friday
David what's for dinner tonight I think
I think takeout tonight I think it's a
sushi night tonight
I've been doing a lot of home cooking
which I love but I do believe that we
are I think it's a takeout night Maddie
I speedy says David did Trump make Kemp
soil himself yesterday I don't know base
tea dragon says was Trump encouraging
huffing because that's basically what I
heard are we going back to the 90s
huffing is bad ok BAE photo says our
bleach infusions covered under Medicare
only at a low rate doctors are gonna
refuse to do them because they won't be
paid enough mister lieutenant pink says
reports from HKS TV that kim jeong-hoon
has died is that true that can't be true
kim jeong-hoon let's see here Kim
jong-un may have lurched
North Korea as health rumors swirl u.s.
monitoring intelligence I'm not seeing
that you know if you if you were
tricking me then you got me but HKS t
v-- kim jeong-hoon
let's see here two hours ago
holy [ __ ] vice director of HKS TV hong
kong satellite television says North
Korean leader Kim jong-un is dead okay I
mean I guess there's a question of
whether that's a trustworthy source who
tweeted this Jennifer Zeng who okay I
don't know who that is I have no idea
you are correct
HKS TV has asserted that Kim Jong moon
is dead we don't know anything else so
you're you're super chat is correct it
doesn't tell us what the truth is
Patrick Nilson says Pakman fair and
balanced Thank You Trey Earnhardt says
I'm thinking of starting an industrial
band called children of the lie is that
a good name well I don't know if you're
joking because I have tried to get a
single song collaboration with Anthony
Mellon Fantana there Stephen Hahn as
well as a Sam cedar and destiny wid that
name and we haven't been able to do it
yet all right let me thank some people
Neil Lewis is new member number four
today
Jake Rennert is new member number five
Donna merwin is new member number six
taro kill Polian has pledged on patreon
and as today's 7th supporter Thomas grow
glar is number eight today bob Nordquist
is new member number nine at join
pakman.com Daniel Dodie you are new
member number ten
Reuben flam Shepherd is new member
number eleven thank you so much a
darboux tel is number 12 I also want to
thank Ben Duncan who is the thirteenth
new member today
and lastly wait a second okay now hold
on did I miss somebody yes Dan Crocker
is new member number fourteen thank you
so much I really appreciate you know
people have reached out
they've said hey David you know I I'm I
did not lose my job and I know you know
you've lost hundreds of members because
of the virus I'm supporting at full
price and I love that but it doesn't
matter what the price is use the coupon
code 2020 now you'll save 66% I don't
care at what level you're supporting the
work that we do any level matters we
estimate that only about three quarters
of one percent of our audience supports
financially three that's zero
we're - no the one that looks like an
egg zero point a dot zero point seven
five percent our supporters and that's
fine right because the whole point is
this is for everybody but if we could
just move that to one point five percent
it's a game-changer it's it flips
everything upside down
in fact if we get to that one point five
percent I should hang from the ceiling
to do the show okay we're gonna switch
to c-span because I prefer the c-span
feed the audio is better and we can see
the reporters it is on about a 15-second
delay so it should start momentarily
here and then we will be off and running
with today's daily press briefing I
expect a lot of drama a lot a lot of
drama today I don't know why c-span
hasn't started yet very strange I guess
we'll go over here for a moment the 8%
new cases in New York are down 50%
compared to a week ago and fatalities
are down 40% over the same period in
Louisiana the rate a positive test
result of decline from 25% down to
positive test great result going down
isn't super relevant if you're doing way
more tests can still be the same number
of people in a number of positive tests
in the last seven day so over the last
seven days been very very significant
progress half of all Americans live in
states that have now taken steps to open
their we got economy percent over the
same period in Louisiana the radio a
positive test result it declined from 25
percent down to 15 percent in the last
seven days alone 18 states now show a
decline
in a number of positive tests in the
last seven days over the last seven days
been very very significant progress half
of all Americans live in states that
have now taken steps to open their
economies
just yesterday governors Gavin Newsom
California Tim Walz of Minnesota and
building of Tennessee announced
additional plans to restart certain
sectors we asked every American to
maintain vigilance and hygiene social
distancing and voluntary use of face
coverings we're opening our country it's
very exciting to see we have a lot of
talent involved from governor's down to
people that just stand there and help
you with the doors there's been
tremendous talent involved and
tremendous spirit from our country
country is a great place and it's going
to be greater than ever before I really
believe that I think there's going to be
a tremendous upward shift I spoke with
back to the Apple and Apple they have a
good sense of the market and he feels
it's going to be a V the V is sharply
upward later on as we actually get it
fully open today I signed the Paycheck
protection program
and health care Enhancement Act
providing 320 billion dollars to keep
American workers on the payroll 30
billion dollars of the Paycheck
protection funds will be reserved for
small financial institutions including
those that serve minority and distressed
communities extending vital relief to
thousands of African American and
Hispanic American small business owners
and their employees the bill also
delivers seventy five billion dollars
for hospitals so badly needed for
hospitals they've taken a very big hit a
hospital providers in areas less
affected by the virus hospitals and
doctors should work with their state and
local health officials on ways to safely
resume elective medical treatments and
care under the cares Act we're sending
direct payments to millions of American
workers more than 80 million Americans
have already received their
$3,400 for a typical family of notice
that the 80 million number has been the
number they've been using since Monday I
mean it was it'll I then has nobody
received a payment since then we just
don't know I mean send out a notice of
what benefits Americans are receiving to
fulfill the requirement the Treasury
Department is mailing a letter to me it
will include the amount their economic
impact payment how it will arrived
direct deposit check or prepaid debit
card as well as a message to the nation
letting each American know that we are
getting through this challenge together
as one American family and that's what's
been happening the whole world is
watching this you have 184 countries out
there that have been hit and now it's
probably higher than that but they're
not watching us they're all watching and
they're calling and they respect what
we're doing so much I spoke with the
leaders of numerous countries today
they're asking if we can send them
ventilators and I'm agreeing to do it we
have tremendous capacity now over
capacity of ventilators we're filling up
stockpiles for our States and for
ourselves federal government is over
10,000 ventilators and we could have a
lot more if we wanted to do that but
we're helping Mexico Honduras Indonesia
France we're sending to France we're
sending to Spain was sending to Italy
and we'll probably be sending to Germany
should they need them over the last
three years we built the strongest
economy and the most successful country
the world has ever seen great economy
the world has ever seen
nobody's ever done anything like what we
were able to do and we will rebuild that
economy our economy in the
not-too-distant future I really believe
with all that we've learned and all that
we've done we'll be just as strong and
may be stronger than ever before
even stronger than it was just two
months ago some interesting note is that
the fda approved the first at-home kovat
19 test kit just got approved and dr.
Stephen were Stephen Stephen Hans
is going to say a couple of words about
that and some other things I want to
thank Stephen the FDA has been
incredible they've been approving not
only this but they've been approving
many things that are paced that's never
happened before and they're being very
safe about it as Steven told me he's
told me told me very strongly but at the
same time they're approving things at
record numbers in a record at a record
rate and it's really been helpful many
tests are going on many vaccine tests
and tests of every different guide and
things are happening just like this
event things are happening very rapidly
even tell you a little bit about it
thank you very much thank you thank you
mr. president
appreciate the opportunity to tell you
about what's happening at the FDA we
have a team of more than 18,000
employees no Burke's or foul Qi today
huh doctors pharmacists and nurses and
they've been working around the clock
because as you probably know many of the
medical products that are being used for
the Cova 19 outbreak are in fact
regulated by FDA the staff have been
hard at work
authorizing tests and other medical
products as part of these efforts to
support diagnostic test development
during this global pandemic the
president has asked us and under its
leadership to actually cut down as many
barriers as we possibly could to get
medical products into the medical
community and we have done that of
course recognizing the urgency of the
situation I do want to emphasize what
the president said that is that we are
very much paying attention to safety at
a with respect to test validity and
reliability of those tests and I think
it's really important to understand how
far we've come in just a few short
months the academic community which I
come from the private sector know this
guy is a doctor but for whatever reason
I always when he's talking feel like
it's a veterinarian who somehow got in
charge of the FDA and we've heard from
many test developers both in academia
and in the manufacturing world this
normally takes years to develop you've
heard dr. Burke's talk about the fact
that HIV tests have taken many many
years to
this has happened in weeks and months
we've been laser focused on working with
both industry and academia to actually
make this happen to date under our
emergency use authorization approach
we've quickly reviewed and authorized 63
tests both diagnostic as well as seer
logic that is the antibody test a
Sullivan
we've had several point-of-care tests
and that's important because those can
be done emergency room when a doctor's
office etc and much more convenient for
the patient and this week as the
president said we authorized the first
at-home tests by a company called lab
core this is a test where under certain
circumstances with a doctor's
supervision a test can be mailed to a
patient and the patient can perform the
self swab and then mail it back and get
the results after that time all under
the guidance of a licensed physician and
we're not just letting up with these 63
tests we've proved we are working with
more than 400 test developers who are
pursuing authorization for their
diagnostic this is all great just
remember the important thing is how many
tests are we processing per day that's
the one thing that matters not the
variety of tests not the number of labs
what not the capacity how many tests are
we doing per day the country have begun
patient testing using their own
validated tests this has allowed us to
increase significantly tests around the
country I updated you earlier this week
on serologic test-- these antibody tests
that are used to detect natural immunity
and the FDA's approach to help make
these tests available well these are
just one part of our larger response
effort they can play a role in helping
move our economy forward by helping
healthcare professionals identify those
who have immunity to the Cova 19 and
just finally when it comes to
therapeutics we are leaving no stone
unturned in finding treatments for kovin
19 you do know that we don't have any
approved currently therapeutics for
koban 19 but we are actively involved
with both the academic and the
commercial and private sector to find
those 72 trials of therapeutics are
underway in the United States under FDA
oversight and 211 are in the planning
stages so we expect to see more this
includes convalescent plasma as well as
antivirals there
peas work continues on vaccines and two
firms have announced that the FDA has
authorized their trials to go forward
one of which we've mentioned here before
and finally in response to the
president's and taskforce requests we've
stood up the coronavirus treatment
acceleration program we are leaving no
stone unturned as I said and we're
working around the clock to develop
these therapeutics for the American
people thank you very much about an hour
ago
a subcommittee with oversight released
some findings that the FDA doesn't have
any review of the antibody tests that
are on the market there are no
guidelines to tell which one should be
out there and there's no way to test
their accuracy they're quite worried
that these are junk tests on the market
because they weren't reviewed before
they were approved is that true so under
our policy we provide a flexibility what
we've told manufacturers is that it's
shorter to market certified they have to
validate their tests they have to tell
us that they validated their knesset
right and then the package insert they
have to let people know and users labs
etc that those tests were not authorized
by FDA we've authorized for as I
mentioned more in the pipeline and these
tests that have come in without any
information to us but have been self
validated as I mentioned at the podium a
couple days ago we are working with the
National Cancer Institute as well as CDC
to perform our own validation of the
tests that that have been sent to us so
we'll provide as much information as we
possibly can and there is transparency
on our website about those tests and
also the tests that we have authorized
are we listening dependence today mr.
president from early in this effort
President Trump is called forth a
whole-of-government response to the
corona virus epidemic in America and by
that the president made clear when he
asked me to lead the White House
coronavirus task force not merely a
whole of the federal government alright
I'll continue with my policy of muting
this is a good opportunity just to play
formulas crazy whoa this is Rudy saying
hey you know we're not doing contact
tracing for cancer we're not doing
contact track contact tracing for
obesity take a listen Michael Bloomberg
is going to handle the tracing army of
tracers in New York we learned today
everybody for cancer yeah our matrix
everybody for cancer and heart disease
and obesity right
you can't cough on someone and make them
obese you can't go to work and sneeze
and all of a sudden ten people are
overweight right I mean so this is crazy
and Laura Ingraham just nods along and
I'm in a lot a lot a lot of things kill
you more than more than covet 19 so we
should be traced for all those things
does he not know what tracing means or
is he an idiot and like I mean or Bo I
guess it's kind of kind of both how
insane is that how insane is that we're
not tracing for obesity can you imagine
it's just absolutely crazy I do want to
do the we'll get back to pensiero in a
second I do want to do my critique of
mark Warner's tuna melt but then I also
some I already kind of got a hint that
some people might find it elitist if I
do my critique so I'm just not sure I
don't know I you know it's like if this
is how you want to make a tuna melt and
do it but to even call it a tuna melt is
probably an atrocity I'll maybe do it
after we'll we'll see let's listen to
pence a little bit of all of our minds
we're working working to make it
possible for every governor to access
the existing capacity to enable our
states to be able to reopen responsibly
under the phased approach that the
president unveiled one week ago a little
bit of context you may recall that one
month ago all told that hosting that had
been done in America 80,000 Americans
had been tested but as of this morning
5.1 million of you know what's relevant
about that pence just admitted as of a
month ago only 80,000 people had been
tested they said by March 27th or the
end of March millions and millions of
people would have been tested he just
admitted it was only 80,000 now he's
using it to brag but it confirms that
they didn't tell us the truth all along
well but people should not be
discouraged by those numbers we are
looking at very positive trends in
hospitalization in emergency room
entrances and we continue to see as
we've said at this podium every day over
the last several weeks we continue to
see positive progress not just on the
west coast but even where the corona
virus epidemic is most deeply impacted
in areas of Greater New York City area
New Orleans Detroit and elsewhere on our
nearly two-hour phone call today with
those governors we heard of the progress
governor's were making in implementing
the resources that we've been working to
provide them not just the medical
equipment but also as you recall that
map a week ago that showed where all of
the equipment is all across the country
in all 50 states
Governor Cuomo joined us for the call
today he spoke favorably of his meeting
here at the White House mr. president
and his recognition that testing is a
partnership between the federal and
state governments as Governor Cuomo said
today that he understood that the
federal government works with national
manufacturing and supply chain and the
governor's deal with the labs to expand
and implement testing at the state level
Governor Cuomo also explained how he's
using his licensing authority as a
governor to stand up the more than 300
labs that can do coronavirus testing in
the state of New York and we
congratulated him for his leadership in
that urged other governors to
they're thought accumulation Tennessee
Governor Bill Lee told us that he's
deployed the National Guard to stand up
more than 20 drive-through test sites
they're testing 10,000 people a day have
already tested more than 130,000 people
in Tennessee and they expect to surge
another 15,000 people in testing sites
this weekend in Tennessee Massachusetts
is an area we're continuing to watch
very closely as cases have not yet
stabilized and governor Charlie Baker
after he he thanked us mr. president for
the Army Corps of Engineers deployment
of four field hospitals he described how
they have rapidly expanded testing all
across Massachusetts we commended him
for that in the beginning of March he
said they had just one testing site in
the state of Massachusetts and now
thanks to governor Charlie Baker's team
they have more than 30 testing sites
Minnesota governor Tim waltz reflected
on the call today about the partnership
he's forged with the Mayo Clinic the
University of Minnesota and State Health
Department they're actually
collaborating to perform 20,000
molecular tests and 15,000 antibody
tests per day and I'm looking forward to
traveling to the Mayo Clinic in
Minnesota on Tuesday of next week I
learned firsthand from the governor
about their efforts across the state to
expand testing Iowa Governor Kim
Reynolds gave us an update mr. president
on her progress she's literally tripling
testing capacity worse day through a
partnership with a private sector with
the University of Iowa and Iowa State
University as she also launched the the
test Iowa dot-com website Wow
which actually creates an access point
for people to fill out a questionnaire
about whether or not their symptoms or
circumstances would justify a test
she's sit in the first 72 hours a
hundred and fifty thousand people went
to the test site to receive an
assessment and I was now testing four
thousand five hundred people a day in
their state in Indiana I spoke also
today with governor of Eric Holcomb
they've tested 72,000 Hoosiers to date
they're adding drive-thru sites they'll
have ten drive through sites established
by the state of Indiana before
I might have done raised governor
Holcomb last week opened up half of
their elective surgery sites and
hospitals across the state and they'll
be opening up the balance of their
elective surgery sites next week in
Maryland another area that we're
watching very closely governor Larry
Hogan expressed appreciation for federal
support as he's continuing to scale
testing he had been in touch with the
National Institute of Health which is
opening up its laboratories for Maryland
to do testing and we were also able to
confirm to him that Walter Reed
hospitals laboratory capacity is
available to Maryland and in Utah mr.
president governor gary Herbert told us
that he actually diverted 1,200 state
employees to do contact tracing in their
state in the last 36 hours 23,000
residents have also signed up for what
they're calling their healthy together
app and they have 50 different testing
locations across Utah and have tested
82,000 people in the state already other
state examples mr. president we're just
as inspiring Governor Phil Murphy of New
Jersey's forged a partnership with
Rutgers University working closely with
the FDA they've authorized this I I'm
still thinking about just this crazy
Rudy Guiliani saying why don't we
contact trace for cancer or obesity like
imagine that phone call imagine and
tracer hello do you work with Joe Schmo
yeah
he's recently been diagnosed as obese
okay like what would that phone call be
like what does it even mean to contact
trace obesity it's very weird repurposed
of their manufacturing lines to create
medical supplies to meet their need
within the state and in Connecticut
Governor Ned Lamont spoke about positive
trend lines in Connecticut which has
been really at the center of the
outbreak in the Greater New York area
but he also said they were hoping to
double testing over the next week mr.
president that's just a sampling of what
we heard today and I I know it's an
encouragement to you and I I trust it's
an encouragement to people all across
the con
not really that in your direction we are
you know you're laying a testing
strategy that is supported at the
federal level but it is deployed and
managed at the state level and we want
to express our appreciation to every
governor across the country that are
that are standing up all of those labs
that has the most worthless VP since Dan
Quayle or is he actually useful in the
sense that he takes attention away from
the fact that Trump can barely put a
sentence together I don't know and we're
going to continue to increase testing
dramatically in the weeks ahead so we
want to thank our governors for the
progress that we're making on testing
and for their role in in urging their
citizens to practice the kind of
mitigation and social distancing efforts
that are really making real progress
we're one team one mission that's to
save lives and because of of all the
efforts that have been made at the state
level and the strong guidance that's
come from the federal level because of
the amazing health care workers across
this country and our first responders
they need that mostly I believe deep in
during those the operation of millions
of Americans who put the guidance into
practice their cooperation and their
prayers have set us on a path where we
are slowing the spread we are protecting
our most vulnerable and I truly do
believe the day will soon come when we
will heal our land right and we'll be
able to reopen America and put this
great nation back to work thank you
oh my god you guys know what just went
on he clearly left because the questions
were going to be about drinking bleach
and it's abundantly clear they didn't
want to do it holy [ __ ] just bailing
altogether by the way I was keeping an
eye on memberships and I really
appreciate all of the 30 people it has
to be that he didn't want to take any
questions on bleach right I mean that I
can't even think about anything I was
trumped just throwing a it was thought
he looked can't let's just go back and
see that it was like tantrum like in a
weird way you see here they will soon
come when we will heal our land and
we'll be able to reopen America and put
this great nation
[Music]
Wow
ok since we have time since this was
shorter let's do just let's do something
fun ok I like Mark Warner he's a
perfectly nice guy he did a video I
can't tell if this is satire or not it
seems to be real this is him making a
tuna melt I'm gonna take this seriously
I'm going to analyze this as a tuna melt
because I have very strong opinions
about tuna melt let's just take a look
at it together ok I will I am NOT going
to be overly critical but I will be I'm
gonna be serious about videos where they
sing song plans
or cook a favorite recipe so I thought
that I would create one of my favorite
all-time recipes now I'm going to be
moving fairly quickly so unless you're a
professional chef you may want to
occasionally pause the video so you can
keep up right know what I think we have
any deposit yeah even a lot I learned to
make it very very young it is truly my
real specialty so today we're going to
create a tuna melt here we go what we
need
well they need some bread we need
mayonnaise we need cheese and we need
good old-fashioned tuna right let's get
that all right first of all two pieces
of red okay so now I never use I just I
don't eat white bread and and I also
don't think that if you're actually
making this a tuna melt in my opinion
the white bread is too weak of a bread
it falls apart under proper grilling and
I would never use white bread for this i
if you need a white ish bread I would
use like a hard crust sourdough but in
my opinion you know a seeded bread can
be great for a tuna melt a whole wheat
bread whatever but for me white bread is
weak bread for suffer a sandwich like
this so two issues here number one
that's a ridiculous amount of mayonnaise
number two you to make a tuna melt you
typically mix the mayonnaise in with the
tuna after you've drained the tuna and
you would put other things in there
sometimes you would pull a little bit of
very finely diced red onion finely diced
celery you don't put the mayonnaise
right on the bread and it's also a crazy
amount of mayonnaise now it gets really
ugly as you can see the tuna is packed
either in water or in oil both are good
it's fine either way but you've got to
drain that stuff you can't he's soaking
white bread we
to NEWater okay you want to fully drain
that I typically squeeze the lid over
the sink and reaiiy actually did this
yesterday you really want to let out the
water then I put it in a colander and
really squeeze it out you want as little
water in there as possible he's pouring
tuna water on the white bread and
mayonnaise this actually is some people
are saying it should be illegal
there are provinces in Argentina where I
was born where this is illegal
across the okay second problem is if
you're gonna do a tuna melt you really
need the tuna needs to be less chunky is
the other thing because when you press
it you really want it more kind of not
opportunist but it can't be this chunky
and this is the put why you would go
through with a fork and yeah it's
getting really bad
the other thing yes you do people are
pointing out you mix the tuna and mayo
first not only do you do that if you're
gonna do a tuna melt you need very
little mayo in fact when I make a tuna
melt I don't I sometimes don't even use
Mayo at all I sometimes will just use
olive oil and a little bit of mustard
just to basically get it to stay
together if you're going to grill it
typically when you do the melt you would
put some butter in the pan and mayo and
I just I don't even think you need Mayo
for a tuna melt but you certainly can do
it you mix it first okay now there are
people who are going really hard against
cheddar
I don't think cheddar is a bad idea for
a tuna melt I would tend to go with a
provolone I like provolone
I could see Swiss Swiss can be good on a
tuna melt if you want to go with
something you know a little more
decadent there are certainly other ideas
I once read about and I read it I read
it out about it in a medical journal of
someone who used Taleggio in a tuna melt
and there were significant repercussions
but I think cheddar is fine I just you
don't want any of that American cheese
stuff there are better options but I
don't think the cheddar is really the
root of the problem here
- sighs man put this on the other side
of the bread put it in Union heating
device I'm going with the MVP five now I
mean obviously you don't use a microwave
you know I would use you can use a grill
bottom pan or you can use a flat saute
pan you can really do it either way it's
a question of whether you want the grill
marks or not and you usually want to
weigh it down with something all
sometimes put a cast-iron skillet on top
to weigh it down if you don't have like
a cinder block which I don't ever keep
around anymore
so you really you want to do it in a pan
you don't want a microwave mayonnaise
you don't want a microwave tuna and you
don't want a microwave bread so this is
where it completely jumps the shark 36
also 30 seconds it's all weird
30 seconds enough time to wash our hands
people also were criticizing his hand
washing technique it's like okay guys
come on he's clearly been home for a
while like some people were very
vigilant and said you really want to
pull your hands out of the water while
you're you know frothing the soap this
is really a cooking video I don't know
that we need to worry about that too
much alright so what do you guys think
is it satire or is it for real satire or
real I want to see what people think
yeah you almost should put the entire
sandwich in a blender I like that idea a
lot of people saying its satire and a
lot of people saying that it's actually
for real real and bad satire it's real
unfortunately people are saying it's
completely real it's obviously fake it
has to be a joke he said on a
coronavirus day yeah satire is dead this
is real this guy clearly doesn't
understand satire he's trolling real
people in significant disagreement I
know everybody thinks they have like the
definitive look take on whether it's
real or not now here's the other thing I
tweeted about this and I said it's a
culinary abomination and a bunch of
people said I was like a privileged
elitist and like this I could take the
same ingredients is 'm like I would use
less mayo which saves money I would use
a different type of bread the bread
price isn't that different if you get a
loaf of whole wheat or a loaf of white
like it was a really weird thing where
people started attacking me saying that
it was really elitist because I
have made it differently and in a pan
it's really really weird yeah hit the
sandwich is terrible and a lot of people
are saying that it is completely and
very real let me say thank you to Keenan
province sure who is new member number
31 today and Tracy Agha who is new
member number 32 thank you to everyone
who signed up thank you to everyone who
joined me if you're wondering where
Trump went Trump did not take questions
today we will just look at it one more
time Trump abruptly walking out my
instinct is that it was and you could
hear the first question which was mr.
president is now the time for sarcasm
claiming that his suggestion of
injecting bleach was sarcasm so no
questions today we will see you probably
Monday depending on what's going on this
weekend I might jump on for a moment if
there are press briefings but probably
probably on Monday thanks to everybody
who joined me it was another wild one
you